this is me and these are some of my
co-workers tonight we're on an epic
adventure defending a village from an
army of dark monsters and trying not to
get ourselves killed
[Music]
welcome to the magical world of Dungeons
and Dragons
the best game I've ever played chapter
one what the is DND D&D is a tabletop
role-playing fantasy game you and your
friends sit around a table and pretend
to be heroes going on an epic adventure
together this is a role-playing game it
takes place entirely in our collective
imagination every D&D game is run by a
DM Dungeon Master you arrive at a small
village on the outskirts of the forest
the villagers watch you nervously as you
enter they seem tired worried the DM is
the main storyteller in D&D they create
and describe the adventure the heroes go
on giving them goals to accomplish and
rewards to motivate them the mayor of
this town and wants someone to
investigate strange sounds coming from a
nearby abandoned mine he's offering a
thousand gold pieces to anyone brave
enough to take the job and while it
might look like the heroes and DM are
playing against each other they're
actually playing with each other the
goal of D&D isn't to kill the other
players there's actually no winning in
D&D the goal is to hang out with your
friends and act like weirdos together so
the DMS job is to create an adventure
that's exciting fun and challenging and
the hero's job is to work together to
survive those challenges and explore the
world the DM has created which brings me
to my favorite part of D&D creating a
hero before you can start adventuring in
D&D you need to create your very own
hero using the D&D Handbook you pick a
race human elf dwarf etc and you pick a
class basically your job fighter wizard
rogue I play Amelia human warlock once
you rock no sorcery I play eyelid Road
elf
Harriette's teeth wing road blaze dragon
more palatable once you've decided what
you want to be you fill out one of these
bad boys a character sheet which is just
a piece of paper that keeps track of
your strengths and weaknesses stuff like
that that character sheet is important
but way more important is what makes
your hero unique deciding what your hero
looks like she has a septum piercing
violet eyes she looks like
fun double think about predator they
predator in your mind how they dress big
sorcerer floppy hat on a rotting
werewolf pelts he doesn't wear a lot of
clothing and whatever little quirks make
them stand out I hand out pamphlets like
a Jehovah's Witness
I carry a Warhammer that's as big as my
body I have a demonic imp who follows me
around what Mother Teresa oh you also
create a motivation for your hero
something that called them to adventure
it can be as lofty as rooting out
evildoers or as simple as getting
treasure once you decided who you'll be
the DM weaves your stories together and
you start playing you pass her the dark
entryway of the abandoned mine the
passageway is narrow suddenly you see a
dark figure in the corner and you keep
playing for a long long time it's
playing D&D I know it seems really
complicated and this thick ass rulebook
doesn't help but at its core all of D&D
is just three steps describe decide roll
the DM describes what's happening in the
corner of the mineshaft you find a
sleeping goblin he's laying down on a
pile of coins he doesn't seem to have
noticed you what do you do the heroes
decide what they want to do I want to
steal the coins excellent and then the
player rolls one of these a 20-sided
dice I don't know singular of dice
historically dice is the plural of die
die is singular you're right I'm trying
to get in for earlier on and then the
player rolls one of these a 20-sided die
to find out if they succeeded or failed
the higher you roll the better I rolled
it to not good while sneaking you knock
over a pile of rocks and the Goblin
shoots up wide-awake then the cycle
starts over the Goblin grabs his club
looks at you and yells unsure door what
do you do
that's D&D in a nutshell and it's that
second step decide that makes the game
so special in most games how you play is
limited by the options the game
designers give you run this direction
fight this thing
save this princess essentially being
railroaded
a story that someone else wrote for you
in DND what you do is totally up to you
maybe you panic and try to run away
maybe you draw your weapon and prepare
to fight
or maybe you try to trick the Goblin
okay I look at the goblin and I say
we'll come and pose as friends 17 the
Goblin lowers his club raises his
eyebrow and says friends the DM sets the
stage but once the game starts no one
person controls where the story goes
session after session the DM built an
adventure that reflects the hero's
choices that goblin you tricked last
week might tell you about a Dragon's
Lair nearby that Dragon's Lair may
contain a valuable treasure you can
steal and stealing that treasure might
attract the attention of an evil wizard
who wants to use it for his own schemes
as the game goes on the decisions you
make will shape the world you play in we
want to karaoke competition we were
slaughtering this band of peasants it
was a total like misunderstanding D&D
doesn't just give you the freedom to
choose it asks you to own those choices
before long you might find yourself
thinking less like you and more like the
hero you're trying to be role playing
all of us are role players we go through
our lives playing different parts for
the people around us some we get to
choose video producer podcaster
co-worker some we have no control over
black female queer even with our friends
we can fall into patterns of behavior
that eventually you become expectations
the wisecracker the cool girl the shy
one roles were so used to playing we
don't even think of them as roles
anymore they're just us D&D gives you
permission to be something different to
surprise yourself and that can be really
scary when you do something in D&D will
come and loose you're trusting everyone
at the table to take you seriously and
you're trusting the other players to
have your back
I pulled flour out of my hair hand it to
him and give him a wink I produce a tiny
rainbow over Harriet's head mother
Teresa does her best Goblin impression
and says it's call there with me
16 18 natural 20 the Goblin looks at you
more relaxed and says friends that
shared vulnerability is what makes D&D
different from any other game you play
with your friends we can spend our whole
lives wandering alone through the
corridors of our minds D&D asks you to
wander together to believe for just a
few hours that there's more to us than
what meets the eye
more silliness more warmth more bravery
and yeah just a little more magic
should you play D&D D&D is ridiculous
but when I ask my friends why they play
D&D they don't talk about the monsters
or the dungeons they talk about how the
game makes them feel it just feels so
free I'm not thinking about you know I
have to do this tomorrow I need to take
care of this at home it just kind of
like brings your inner child back out
nobody makes fun of anybody nobody feels
self-conscious about it over that you
get the more expectations people have a
new D&D there aren't any expectations I
can just be free like I feel like the
rest of the world doesn't matter like
I'm always super stoked to play like a
fun really creative way to connect with
each other and I think it's made us
really grow closer the way that you look
at the people you were just playing with
is really different than other people in
the real world because you've engaged in
something so collaborative and imagined
together pointers and world building
together but the real point of D&D is
like you're in this bubble of these
people you're entirely focused on each
other and remembering all the reasons
that you like spending time with their
characters but also spending time with
them as human beings if you look past
the Wizards path the dungeons and
magical creatures D&D is a game about
the people you play with a game where
everyone agrees to bring their weirdness
and creativity to the tape
to help build a world that belongs to
all of you a world shaped by your
triumphs your defeats your personality
quirks and your stupid inside jokes a
world that could not have existed if you
and your friends hadn't sat down at a
table one day and said let's play
believe it or not this video is not
sponsored by D&E we're just huge nerds
but if you're interested in playing you
should check out the D&D starter set
it comes with a premade campaign
character sheets a mini rulebook and
dice and if you're interested in seeing
more videos about games check out our
sister site polygon they have this cool
new series called in zone which talks
about how games shape and reflect our
culture killed it that time that's a
wrap baby